j'ouvre tout de suite notre seconde
débat des bas de société consacrée ce
soir aux nouvelles dérives sectaires 11
millions de Français il y aurait déjà eu
à faire phénomène accentué par les
réseaux sociaux qu'on va décortiquer
avec mes invités mais d'abord je vous
propose un reportage le témoignage de
Grégoire Paray dénonce les
établissements Steiner valdorf il a été
scolarisé pendant 10 ans la mi-vilud
appelle à la vigilance sur ces écoles
mais elles ont toujours pignons sur rue
Samia dechir avec Adrien
15 ans qu'il n'a pas remis les pieds
dans cette forêt quand il revient sur
les lieux les souvenirs de Grégoire
Perrin remontent immédiatement à la
surface quelle horreur ce lieu on y est
à la clairière de de sable alors c'est
là qu'il y avait lieu les cours de sport
de l'école Steiner et en fait tout
autour de ce lieu il y avait les
exactions des élèves sur les autres les
passages à tabac systématiques des
blessures les exactions sexuelles les
il nous est mangé nos excréments des
actes qui se seraient déroulés sous le
regard des professeurs pour les
professeurs des écoles Steiner les
élèves qui viennent dans une classe il
serait incarnent ils ont des comptes
karmiques à régler et il faut leur
laisser régler leurs comptes y compris
par la violence à quelques mètres de là
l'école Steiner de Verrières-le-Buisson
dans l'Essonne un établissement sous
contrat avec l'Éducation nationale ou
Grégoire Perrin a été scolarisé de ses 9
ans à ses 18 ans ça me rend triste ça
m'écœure ça me ça me révolte que cette
école soit encore là et pignon sur rue
affiche ses portes ouvertes et alors
qu'elle devrait être interdite alors que
dans une république ce genre d'école n'a
pas sa place l'endoctrinement n'a pas sa
place dans l'enseignement les enseigner
ce n'est pas endoctriné ce n'est pas
transmettre les croyances délirantes de
l'anthroposophie l'anthroposophie c'est
un mouvement créé par Rudolf Steiner au
début du 20e siècle ces adeptes croient
en l'existence d'un monde invisible
régie par des forces cosmiques Grégoire
Perrin a gardé tous ses cahiers des
colliers le soleil pour les
entrepreneurs a émergé de la terre à un
moment donné et la Lune également et
c'est ça pour les anthroposophes qui a
créé la division des sexes je regarde ce
cahier voyez cinquième jour la
séparation du soleil et de la lune
correspond à la séparation lors de la
sixième phase de la formation de
l'embryon des théories subtilement
dissimulées à l'éducation nationale et
aux parents qui croient inscrire leurs
enfants dans une école à la pédagogie
alternative de type freiner ou
Montessori on est complètement imprégné
pénétré par cette doctrine
dont on n'a pas conscience parce que en
fait le problème c'est que cette
doctrine n'est pas nommée donc on sait
pas que c'est de l'anthroposophie
endoctriner Grégoire Perrat devient
lui-même professeur dans une école
Steiner mais il fait aussi des études de
philosophie qui vont l'amener à tout
remettre en question
dont je suis fière parce que c'est la
quand j'avais 39 ans en fait j'ai rompu
avec l'anthroposophie et j'ai rompu en
le disant clairement lors d'une
conférence à la Société Anthroposophique
à cet instant là je viens de faire ma
conférence en leur expliquant qu'ils
étaient une secte Grégoire Perrette
devient alors le premier Français à
dénoncer publiquement les dérives de
l'anthroposophie et des écoles Steiner
un engagement qu'il va payer très cher
il y a eu les procès il y a eu le
harcèlement les processus de diffamation
de rumeurs sur sur ma personne dans le
but de briser toute vie personnelle et
professionnelle donc moi en fait depuis
10 ans je vis avec des menaces de mort
des menaces d'agression physique des
gens qui me suivent dans la rue des gens
qui me dit femme sur les réseaux sociaux
et il y a aucune protection par rapport
à ça
Grégoire Perrin a gagné tous ses procès
contre les représentants de
l'anthroposophie depuis 2018 le
gouvernement a reçu plus de 50
signalements pointant des risques de
dérive sectaires dans les écoles Steiner
pour débattre autour de ces nouvelles
dérives sectaires accueil Sonia baquets
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes secrétaire
d'été en charge de la citoyenneté vous
avez organisé les premières Assises
nationales de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires et Isabelle fétide bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
documentariste créatrice du podcast meta
de choc Jean-Louis adénormes bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi à chef adjoint
Charlie Hebdo et auteur de du nouveau
péril sectaire livre publié aux éditions
Robert Laffont on est également en
duplex avec Thomas Huchon journaliste
investigation spécialiste du numérique
et auteur bonsoir Thomas de anti fake
news que vous avez écrit avec
Jean-Bernard Schmitt et qui est publié
aux éditions First bienvenue à vous
aussi Mathilde sero évidemment est resté
à mes côtés Sonia Baguet on va
évidemment réagir à ce reportage pour
commencer la l'individu de la mission
intermicelle le vigilance et de lutte
contre les dérives sectaires on les a
contactés dans le cadre de ce reportage
nous ont répondu ils affirment ne pas
disposer d'éléments permettant de
caractériser une dérive sectaire au sein
de ces écoles Steiner pourtant la milite
reconnaît recevoir chaque année des
signalements ça prouve quoi ça prouve la
difficulté finalement de définir ce
qu'est une secte de caractériser de
prendre ce type de décision oui
aujourd'hui on a on a clairement sans
doute des outils qui nous manquent c'est
la raison pour laquelle on a organisé
ces assises pour avoir des propositions
concrètes pour faire évoluer les choses
là on parle des écoles Steiner on a un
QG énorme de l'Église de Scientologie
qui a qui réussit à s'installer en
banlieue parisienne enfin c'est on a
aujourd'hui très clairement des outils
qui nous manquent sur ces sur ce genre
de fait on a besoin de pouvoir qualifier
plus simplement
l'effet l'emprise dans son victime les
personnes et il y a un gros travail à
faire sur la poursuite des auteurs parce
que dans nos conclusions il y a toute la
question de la prévention comment on
fait pour que les gens évident de
rentrer de l'aide aux victimes et puis
surtout à la fin les auteurs comment on
les poursuit on voit bien qu'il y a des
procès qui durent pendant des années et
des années et donc comment on se donne
les outils j'envoie des non je crois que
vous connaissez bien ce ce dossier
Comment comment vous expliquer que
malgré les signalements et ces écoles
est toujours pignons sur rue certains
certaines sont sous contrat de
l'éducation nationale alors comment je
l'explique je pense qu'il y a
effectivement une question d'outils
qu'il faut qu'il faut réussir à mettre
en place je pense qu'il y a aussi une
question de contrôle les écoles dans les
écoles Steiner il y a une vraie un vrai
savoir-faire en terme de dissimulation
je crois que c'est ce que Grégoire
explique très bien on a des cas où il y
a de faux cahiers qui sont qui sont
utilisés par les élèves pour faire
croire que le programme est suivi on a
recueilli il y a peu de temps un
témoignage d'un garçon qui explique
qu'il y a des objets qui sont dissimulés
et la doctrine en elle-même la doctrine
de rudol Steiner est une doctrine qui
qui a été construite pour être dissimulé
c'est-à-dire qu'il a il a théorisé
lui-même le fait qu'il fallait cacher à
la fois aux parents d'élèves au pouvoir
politique le fait que les écoles cher ou
les écoles où il y a une spiritualité
qui est inculqué aux enfants et que dans
ces cas-là il y a un risque de dérive
sectaire c'est en cela que le témoignage
de Grégoire Perrin est extrêmement
important et je content d'ailleurs vous
l'ayez passé parce qu'il y a quelques
années c'était très très difficile de
travailler sur ce sujet il y avait
quelques personnes qui ont été un peu
précurseur je pense notamment à
Elizabeth qui est qui est ici sur son
plateau ce soir qui a fait ce travail de
un travail d'enquête un travail
journalistique qui consiste à révéler ce
que les gens ne voient pas dans ces
écoles et le fait que vous ayez passé ce
soir ce documentaire avait ce reportage
pardon avec Grégoire pour moi c'est un
grand progrès parce qu'il y a encore
quelques années on en aurait jamais
parlé à la télévision ils avaient fait
une parce que il y a une capacité de
résistance même juridique judiciaire de
la part alors on peut peut-être élargir
sortir du seul cas des des écoles
Steiner mais c'est ce qui s'est passé on
l'a vu avec si plein temps diffamation
toute perdus d'ailleurs par les écoles
et remporté par Grégoire parat il y a
voilà c'est il y a des soutiens aussi
est-ce qu'on peut dire ça sans doute
sans doute c'est possible après je crois
qu'il y a aussi une question moyen
d'enquête c'est à dire que pour
caractériser une dérive secteur et il y
a effectivement des critères pour ça
juridique et ben il faut avoir des
éléments et c'est déjà compliqué de
caractériser dans absolue une des
récepteurs mais si en plus on n'a pas
des moyens d'enquêter derrière en amont
en fait ça devient très compliqué on
voit le cas par exemple avec
actuellement Thierry casasnovas qui est
qui est allé en garde en garde à vue et
qui propose des pratiques hygiénistes
trudivores qui sont à la limite en plus
de l'exercice illégal de l'amitié mais
pour condamner une personne qui a ce
type d'activité avec des adeptes avec
des gens peut-être sous emprise mentale
etc il faut avoir des faut avoir des
éléments et ça du coup c'est aussi la
grande question actuellement c'est qui
peut enquêter qui a les moyens qui a le
temps qui a les moyens en personne aussi
en effectif ça pose la question des
effectifs de la mivilud qui sont quoi
sous-évalués aujourd'hui il faut pas
tout ramener aux affecter aux effectifs
mais on a on a acté au moment des
assises l'augmentation de 25% des
effectifs de la mivilud mais il y a
aussi les moyens d'enquête et ça a été
évoqué et il y a aussi la difficulté à
qualifier l'emprise mentale la
suggestion psychologique qui
effectivement un élément très compliqué
il y a quelques semaines vous m'auriez
invité ici vous m'auriez dit pourquoi
Thierry casasnova ça continue à pouvoir
diffuser ces vidéos au final c'est
toujours trop long et c'est aussi trop
long pour pour nous mais au final il est
aujourd'hui mis en examen c'est pas
c'est la justice fera son travail mais
on finit par arriver à faire des choses
il y a des procès qui sont en cours sur
un certain nombre d'organisations mais
effectivement il y a des moyens
d'enquête peut-être à travailler ça fait
partie des choses sur lesquelles on
travaille de manière interministérielle
notamment sur des questions
d'infiltration par exemple de capacité à
rentrer finalement et de voir les choses
parce que ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure par Jean-Louis Denner sur la
capacité dissimulation c'est évidemment
un élément majeur de dérive secteur
parce qu'en fait il construisent leur
leurs produits en fait en expliquant que
le reste de la société vous ment le
reste de la société n'est pas crédible
etc donc du coup les les les adeptes
quand ils sont interrogés ils se
protègent de ce qui est dangereux parce
que le monde extérieur est dangereux et
donc forcément ils disent ce que
l'organisation leur a dit de dire et il
y a peut-être une question aussi je
reviens vers vous Jean-Louis de
formation des policiers des magistrats
qui sont confrontés
je vais vous donner un exemple il y a
quelques mois j'avais une victime qui
m'expliquait que elle quittait le la
dérive le groupe à caractère sectaire
dans lequel elle se trouvait et que son
mari restait dans le groupe donc elle a
voulu elle a voulu divorcer elle a
entamé une procédure on sait qu'un
divorce ça peut être très compliqué on
sait les problèmes qu'on peut rencontrer
à ce moment-là et son avocat lui a dit
au moment de la procédure surtout ne
parlez pas de la question sectaire ça va
perdre le juge on va rentrer dans une
autre un autre type d'affaires et
compagnie ça c'est très grave parce que
pour elle c'était impossible de parler
de cette séparation sans évoquer le fait
que son ex-compagnon était dans une dans
un dans un groupe à caractère sectaire
donc c'est montrer pas que les
magistrats sont méprisants ou qu'ils ou
qu'il ne croient pas la deuxième secteur
c'est montrer qu'il y a c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire que de
rajouter la notion sectaire dans une
affaire et on sait que dans les affaires
de dérive sectaire il y a des cas de
violences physiques des cas de violences
sexuelles des cas de consommation de des
cas de 2000 sous influence des cas de
captation de d'argent de voilà et dans
toutes ces tous ces critères sont
importants mais ils ne peuvent pas être
pris en compte sans tenir compte de
l'aspect sectaire donc de la mise sous
emprise de l'abolition de l'esprit
critique d'une personne qui se trouve
dans une dans un cas de d'emprise
sectaire alors notre débat il porte sur
ses nouvelles dérives sectaires on va
voir si elles le sont vraiment leur
amplification par les réseaux sociaux
les signalements sont en hausse d'après
les chiffres donnés par la mi-vilaine
plus de 4000 signalements en 2021 ça
représente une hausse de 86% par rapport
aux chiffres de 2015 Thomas Huchon je
viens vers vous parce que vous nous
écoutez depuis le début de ce débat et
on en vient à la question effectivement
des liens entre des rives sectaires et
et réseaux sociaux médias sociaux
pourquoi les médias sociaux
amplifient-il le phénomène
c'est assez simple il donne une une
nouvelle manière de diffuser tout cela
et grosso modo il y a 20 ans il y a 30
ans si vous vouliez recruter des adeptes
pour votre mouvement sectaire mais aller
sur un marché discuter avec les gens
dans la vraie vie et c'était donc très
compliqué aujourd'hui il y a une espèce
de double mécanique qui se met en place
c'est à dire que on a des gourous 2.0
comme vous les avez qualifiés qui
utilisent les réseaux sociaux pour
trouver des adeptes et on a dans le même
temps un truc un petit peu pervers de la
part de ces plateformes numériques qui
est que comme elles vont mettre en avant
ce qui capte notre attention elles vont
chercher à
nous maintenir le plus longtemps
connecté et quand elle sentent que vous
avez une petite inclinaison à apprécier
des discours qui vont dans le sens d'une
dérive sectaire mais ils vont pas vous
montrer la contradiction ils vont vous
pousser dans ces contenus là et donc il
y a une espèce de de prime un peu
mécanique et mathématique à la
désinformation on l'avait vu sur les
questions de de radicalisation politique
à l'extrême droite on l'avait vu sur les
questions de radicalisation
religieuse avec le djihadisme et on le
voit depuis un certain nombre d'années
avec la radicalisation vers des dérives
sectaires le complotisme devient une
forme de de porte d'entrée dans tous ces
discours une porte d'entrée qui est déjà
assez chargé idéologiquement mais qui
est effectivement assez loin de ces
discours de gourou et qui petit à petit
vidéo après vidéo vous amène là-dessus
on parlait à l'instant de ce gourou
Thierry casasnovas Thierry casasnovas
c'est plus de 600 000 followers sur
Youtube le gouvernement français peut
essayer de faire des choses mais il y a
un moment il faut aussi que YouTube
fasse le ménage alors ça on va
évidemment y venir et on reparlera des
liens entre complotisme et des rives
sectaires parce que c'est c'est
passionnant Élisabeth fétide sur votre
podcast vous avez des émissions qui sont
dédiées aux personnes qui qui sont sous
emprises ou qui sortent de des emprises
sectaires qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
souvent hameçonnées enfin attirer
justement via internet et les réseaux
sociaux pas forcément souvent qui fait
que les gens s'intéressent ou entrent
dans un groupe qui à terme va les mettre
sous emprise c'est souvent une
connaissance une personne en qui elles
ont confiance en fait parce que on va
pas arriver dans un groupe comme ça au
pif alors soit c'est un sujet qui les
intéresse ça peut être une entrée par
l'alimentation par le développement
personnel par le yoga par tout un tas de
pratiques qui sont même l'écologie qui
qui peuvent en leur sein en fait avoir
des idées promouvoir des idées qui sont
en lien avec de la spiritualité la
spiritualité New Age la spiritualité
contemporaine et de fil en aiguille vont
se retrouver dans un système qu'ils
n'ont pas identifié mais qu'il aimait
sous emprise mais les réseaux sociaux
fabriquent aussi ça des communautés oui
mais ça peut se regrouper oui ça peut se
recouper disons qu'il y a une
banalisation je dirais du discours de la
spiritualité ou du complotisme sur les
réseaux sociaux mais ça veut pas
forcément dire que c'est par ce biais là
que la personne va entrer bien sûr qui a
des dérives sectaires qui sont très
spécifiquement liés à Internet mais
c'est pas forcément systématique
bon courage pour s'attaquer à YouTube
mais en fait alors de quel moyen un état
dispo
les plateformes viennent lors des
assises sectaires ce qui déjà est un
alors qu'est-ce qui répondent à la
démonstration faite partout des
algorithmes qui poussent les contenus
complotistes ou l'algorithme il est vrai
pour les dérives sectaires mais vous
vous intéressez à une voiture rouge vous
n'allez plus voir que des voitures
rouges pendant quelques jours sur votre
fil d'actualité donc l'algorithme fait
que on ne vous montre plus que ce à quoi
vous vous intéressez donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire avec les plateformes et
c'est ce qu'on est en train et on a un
certain nombre de plateformes vous avez
cités Youtube qui va dans le bon sens
qui dit on a besoin de plusieurs choses
un nos modérateurs sont pas formés ce
qui est ce qui a été évoqué par
Jean-Louis Denner tout à l'heure sur les
avocats c'est vrai pour les avocats
c'est vrai pour les magistrats c'est
vrai pour les forces de sécurité c'est
vrai aussi pour les plateformes c'est à
dire que pour qu'on leur demande de
d'enlever des contenus qui sont
dangereux il faut qu'ils sachent les
identifier ça c'est la deuxième chose et
ensuite il y a donc la question de la
formation la question de retirer très
rapidement des des contenus dangereux ça
c'est une convention qu'on a proposé de
signer avec eux et ils sont plutôt
partants là-dessus et que eux aussi
soient en capacité dans le cadre d'un
partenariat gagnant-gagnant de nous
signaler les contenus que eux parce que
nous on n'est pas non plus tout le temps
sur les réseaux sociaux nous signaler
des contenus dangereux qui mériteraient
un signalement article je voyais Thomas
Huchon un peu dubitatif je veux dire ça
comme ça pourquoi c'est pas un peu
dubitatif c'est qu'en fait c'était
comment dirais-je
le discours des Gafa notamment de
Facebook par exemple c'est de dire que
il faut être deux pour danser le tango
et donc grosso modo quand vous êtes sur
un réseau social vous dansez le tango
avec les contenus c'est-à-dire que ce
que vous voyez c'est votre faute à vous
je crois pas du tout que ça soit la
réalité et je crois que justement le
problème de Youtube c'est que entre un
gamin de 14 ans qui nous dit que la
terre est plate ou Thomas Pesquet qui
revient de la station internationale et
bien il va plutôt pousser le gamin de 14
ans qui dit que la terre est parce que
ça buse plus et donc il n'y a pas que ce
que nous faisons nous dont nous sommes
en gros la responsabilité de ce que nous
voyons sur les réseaux elle n'est pas
que de nous elle est aussi des
plateformes et effectivement Thomas
c'est une question que moi j'aurais
adoré poser au représentants des Gafa
lors des assises mais effectivement ils
étaient dans une autre salle que celle
dans laquelle j'avais été conviée pour
réfléchir quand même préciser un élément
l'une des forces bien sûr c'est un
hasard attendez je je sais très bien
tout ça non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que l'une des forces de demander à
changer de salle vous auriez pu bien
entendu je le sais bien madame
secrétaire d'État il n'y a aucun
problème j'ai préféré être un bon élève
et travailler jusqu'au bout non ce que
je veux dire c'est que l'une des forces
de ces mouvements sectaires c'est aussi
leur capacité de nuisances moi ça fait
20 ans que je suis journaliste
d'investigation il y a que deux fois
dans ma vie où j'ai été menacé de procès
par des gens dont j'avais parlé dans mes
reportages la première fois c'est
l'Église de Scientologie le tout début
de ma carrière et plus récemment
que j'avais invité Elisabeth dans mon
émission sur LCI à l'époque et bien nous
avions reçu un courrier de la part de la
Société Anthroposophique qui nous
menaçait de poursuites pour lui avoir
donné la parole donc je suis ravi que
vous l'ayez inviter ce soir je suis ravi
que Grégoire et la parole aussi mais ça
montre aussi cette espèce de
judiciarisation permanente qui est menée
par ces organisations et qui est une
manière de faire taire la contestation
et de dire aux gens et bien ne nous
critiquez pas vous allez avoir des
problèmes c'est aussi une des manières
qu'ils ont de gagner ce combat un peu
déloyal dans lequel nous nous trouvons
face à eux on s'y attendait mais on va
bien regarder notre courrier dans les
prochains jours évidemment on l'a bien
compris je voudrais vous avez parlé de
Scientologie et on va en parler
évidemment maintenant il faudrait vous
montrer une photographie parce que
Jean-Loup adénor vous nous avez alerté
sur cette photographie c'est une
photographie qui date doute 2004 où on
voit Nicolas Sarkozy à l'époque ministre
de l'Intérieur recevoir Tom Cruise
pourquoi pour vous cette photo elle est
elle est symbolique elle marque une
sorte de de rupture ou de Bastille alors
c'est un c'est un point qu'on peut
prendre c'est un nous avec mon coeur
Timothée doroglodo on a pris comme
repère dans le l'histoire de la lutte
contre les dérives sectaires parce
qu'effectivement lorsqu'on ce qu'on
considère comme historiquement la grande
période de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires c'est les années 80-90 qui
aboutissent la création de la Miviludes
en 2002 de mémoire je peux me tromper
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que les années
qui ont suivi c'est-à-dire les années
2000 et encore aujourd'hui encore
aujourd'hui on verra je pense qu'il y a
eu du nouveau mais bon il y a eu un
désintérêt de de du politique pour la
question des dérives sectaires pour
plusieurs raisons peut-être parce que
l'islamisme a pris beaucoup de place et
a raison peut-être parce que il y a
aussi eu cette espèce de paradigme
américain qui c'est un peu installé
selon lequel finalement tant qu'il y a
pas vraiment de cas gravissime chacun
est libre et il faut laisser les
mouvements cultuels
ésotériques s'installer et et et
s'épanouir cette photo est intéressante
c'est qu'effectivement Nicolas Sarkozy a
reçu Tom Cruise c'est pas le seul
d'ailleurs et qu'à l'époque ça
directrice de cabinet dit que ce n'est
pas nous c'est pas son cabinet c'est pas
Nicolas Sarkozy de décider de ce qui est
une secte ou non ça c'est intéressant
parce que sans faire de liste sans
mettre de tampon bien sûr que c'est la
puissance publique de s'intéresser à ce
que font les groupes et les mouvements
qui sont présents sur son sol bien sûr
que c'est important de savoir où les
enfants vont à l'école bien sûr que
c'est important de savoir si une école
est une école une école qui qui professe
un type de spiritualité qui met les
enfants sous emprise est-ce que les
parents sont au courant de tout ça je
veux dire bien sûr que c'est la
puissance publique de le faire donc
cette photo nous on l'a on a pris mais
voilà on pourrait prendre j'imagine
d'autres bornes dans le dans ces 20
dernières années pour le dire mais on a
pris ce point pour dire voilà qui a eu
un désintérêt alors moi ce qu'on a
plusieurs années après ce que ce que je
note c'est je vais le dire par honnêteté
journalistique également c'est
qu'effectivement là il y a une prise de
conscience de la puissance publique et
le secrétaire d'État en est la
représentante ce soir une prise de
conscience de la gravité du phénomène
mais il faut dire que cette prise de
conscience elle vient aussi après un
moment qui a été un moment terrible qui
a été le covid alors ça on y reviendra
après pardon de nous interrompre parce
que c'est effectivement un élément très
important mais Sonia baquet je reviens
vers vous parce que vous la connaissez
bien malheureusement cette cette secte
de la scientologie votre maman y a été
embrigadé une grande partie de sa vie et
vous avez choisi d'en parler
publiquement juste avant le le lancement
des des Assises nationales il y a deux
semaines pourquoi oui alors j'en ai je
suis lu élu locale depuis 15 ans j'ai
fait le choix de ne pas en parler avant
pour des raisons personnelles pas
forcément envie d'étaler ma vie mais je
considère que
ce combat-là est un combat amener alors
effectivement il a sans doute été
dépassé par les événements qui ont eu
lieu en matière terrorisme en matière de
lutte contre la radicalisation tout ça
finalement pris beaucoup d'espace et
sans doute mis un peu de côté la
question de la lutte contre les rives
sectaire le covid a fait exploser les
chiffres et encore une fois je le répète
on a que une partie très très émergée de
l'iceberg on sait très bien que les 4000
signalements annuels de la mi-vilud sont
une toute petite partie de la réalité il
y a beaucoup de gens qui ont qui ne
veulent pas en parler qui ont peur qui
ne savent pas enfin moi j'en ai fait
partie avant d'être au gouvernement qui
ne sais pas comment aider ses proches à
en sortir tout simplement d'où le fait
que en fait on a vraiment besoin d'avoir
une communication la plus large possible
parce que les gens s'imaginent que les
dérives sectaires c'est un gourou avec
une grande toge et un chapeau pointu
c'est pas ça un gourou ça a été dit tout
à l'heure c'est à dire qu'on est
embarqué par une connaissance par
quelqu'un qui a qui on a confiance et
souvent le gourou c'est quelqu'un qui
est capable de nous séduire donc il nous
fait pas peur au départ donc tout le
monde peut rentrer donc on aborde
vraiment besoin de communiquer fortement
on a besoin de se construire des outils
pour que derrière il puisse y avoir les
signalements aujourd'hui les gens ne
savent pas comment signaler et donc il y
a tout un travail à faire et ça a été
évoqué mais de formation mais aussi de
territorialisation quand quelqu'un est
touché qui puisse le dire et quand on a
des alertes et bien qu'il puisse y avoir
une remontée d'informations pour qu'on
puisse aller chercher les auteurs on a
beaucoup parlé des moyens des outils on
parlait aussi de la régulation des
grandes plateformes sur ces problèmes de
dérive sectaires et vous avez exprimé la
nécessité de renforcer international
législatif concrètement qu'est-ce qui
manque aujourd'hui au droit pour lutter
contre ces derniers sectaires ou
peut-être mieux prévenir mieux
sanctionner et est-ce que vous êtes en
mesure ce soir de nous annoncer
peut-être un projet de loi ou une
initiative de cet ordre là au niveau
gouvernemental alors oui il y aura une
initiative elle sera gouvernementale ou
parlementaire parce que on a voulu aussi
faire de ce moment un moment
trans partisan donc on a invité tous les
groupes à venir participer à ces assises
des dérives sectaires tous les groupes
ont participé à l'exception d'un seul et
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de dire cette
problématique elle concerne tout le
monde et elle concerne pas seulement le
gouvernement elle se concerne pas
seulement quelques-uns donc il y aura
une initiative législative parce que
effectivement il nous manque des outils
alors tout n'a pas été n'a pas été
proposé on n'a pas été au bout parce
qu'il y a un travail interministériel la
monnaie mais les assises ont fait des
propositions et notamment
un certain nombre de propositions sur
les la question des dérives sectaires à
vocation
issues du thérapeutique issu de la
domaine de la santé avec la question
notamment de la mise en place d'un délit
de d'incitation à l'arrêt du traitement
ça c'est un élément important les
cancers par exemple exactement un
travail aussi sur l'encadrement de ce
qu'on appelle les pratiques de soins non
conventionnels comment on fait pour
distinguer le le la personne qui va vous
encourager à manger sainement ce qui est
normal et la personne qui va vous
encourager à arrêter votre traitement et
à en échange manger des légumes est-ce
que on a tous les outils ça a été évoqué
par Elisabeth tout à l'heure sur les
pouvoirs d'enquête on a un travail à
mener là-dessus sans aucun doute et puis
après sur la question des plateformes il
y a sans doute un travail européen à
monnaie à mener qui va être aussi un peu
lourd quel est le groupe politique qui a
refusé le groupe écologiste le groupe
écologiste intéressant pourquoi
je m'adresse à l'expert non mais je
trouve que alors je ne vise absolument
pas repécologie les Verts
particulièrement je pense plutôt à la
sphère à la soirée colo mais je vais pas
dire de grands secrets en disant ça je
pense que dans les dérives donc je
m'appelle les dérives New Age donc c'est
tout en ensemble de de
tout un de encore plus de pensée si on
veut on trouve un certain nombre de gens
qui sont proches de l'écologie alors je
dis pas du tout que ça justice ça
explique le choix de LPS sur la comète
mais bon on est vraiment dans une
démarche transpartie qui va de la fille
on avance dans notre débat et je vous
propose d'entendre une réaction
inexplication du président de la mivil
de sur ses nouveaux gourous d'Internet
en écoute Christian Gravel l'un des
éléments clés de cette évolution du
phénomène sectaire c'est d'abord la
révolution numérique son impact
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux et donc
la démultiplication de micro
influenceurs sectaire l'une des
caractéristiques aussi liée à
l'émergence du web c'est la croissance
exponentielle des théories complotistes
et de l'hybridation que nous avons
constaté avec les phénomènes sectaires
puisque bien évidemment c'est théories
complotistes permettent d'alimenter et
des discours visant à rompre justement
avec le reste de la société
et sur ce thème je propose à terme
traduit de nous rejoindre tout de suite
sur ce plateau rebonsoir Tam puisque
justement vous vous êtes intéressé à ces
à ces liens entre les théories
complotistes les directs et ces théories
qui remettent en cause des vérités
scientifiques oui et Thomas Huchon
parler tout à l'heure je me suis
intéressé au mouvement terre de
plaquiste ce qui pense et disent que la
terre est plate et non ronde il n'y a
pas besoin d'aller chercher bien loin
sur le web vous écrivez terre plate
terre plane dans votre moteur de
recherche et rapidement vous tombez sur
ce type de vidéo
au repos reste toujours horizontal et
n'a pas la capacité de montrer une
convexité ou une forme quelconque sur sa
surface
vérifiable mais complètement en
contradiction avec ce que nous dit sur
le globe si la terre était vraiment une
sphère recouverte de 71% d'eau les
océans devraient être en quelque sorte
courbé pour se coller à tous les côtés
d'une boule en rotation rapide suspendue
dans l'espace
et en réalité il est tout simplement
impossible de faire en sorte que l'eau
se comporte de cette façon ah ça fait
sourire tout le monde sur le plateau
voilà une vidéo énoncée d'un ton docte
avec des arguments qui n’est pourtant
pas si facile de réfuter parce que la
force du platisme c'est que c'est
difficile de montrer que la terre est
ronde ça demande des connaissances
scientifiques physiques mathématiques
poussées si je vous demande si la terre
est ronde vous allez me dire Thomas
j'espère oui oui merci Thomas mais parce
que c'est pour vous une vérité que vous
ne remettez pas en cause mais si je vous
demande de me démontrer je pense que
vous n'en n'êtes pas capable
immédiatement sauf si vous m'avez qu'à
chaque fois que vous aviez un doctorat
physique ou des grands regardez
l'horizon on va se rendre compte que
voilà si on est un peu en hauteur on va
se rendre compte de quelque chose bref
c'est contre vérité scientifique elle
gagne du terrain notamment chez les
jeunes et oui un jeune sur 6 pense que
la terre est plate et selon un sondage
de l'Ifop vous avez aussi près de 20 %
des 18 24 ans en France qui pensent que
les pyramides ont été construites par
des extraterrestres mais Thomas
saurez-vous me démontrer le contraire
mon père qu'on se faisait des fusées je
sais pas si ça va me servir à quelque
chose mais bon voilà et plus globalement
les jeunes sont de plus nombreux de plus
en plus nombreux à penser que la science
apporte plus de bien que de mal tout
cela s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une
révolution informative majeure les
jeunes qui s'informent de plus en plus
via les réseaux sociaux qui estiment que
le nombre d'abonnés d'un influenceur
attestent sa crédibilité les médias
traditionnels qui sont en recul quand
ils ne suscitent pas même la défiance et
les sachants qui ont pour eux de moins
en moins de crédibilité pour certains et
dans le contexte post covid et bien
c'est un public particulièrement
réceptif aux fake news médicales nocives
et au discours complotistes
ce discours ces discours complotistes et
les dérives sectaires et je vais vous
donner un exemple un exemple précis
issu du rapport de 2021 de la mi-vilaine
qui parle du cas de Christian talchaller
écouter ce qu'il disait du vaccin contre
le covid une fois que vous aurez ce
vaccin covid si ils arrivent à le faire
vous ne n'aurez plus aucune liberté
parce que c'est nanoparticules grâce à
la 5G pour vous relire l'intelligence
artificielle de Monsieur Billier et ses
copains et ses copains et à ce moment-là
ils pourront faire ceux qui veulent de
vous voilà ce gourou qui se dit médecin
diffuse des théories complotistes et
puis il s'appuie dessus pour développer
des dérives thérapeutiques avec parfois
des effets dramatiques exemple en 2016
une mère alerte la mi-vilud sur une
formation qui a suivi son fils malvoyant
avec Christian tache chaleur et qui la
conduit à jeûner 30 jours et au bout de
cette période il est forcément très
affaibli il se voit proposé un placement
financier par les organisateurs de la
formation là on a tous les éléments de
la dérive sectaire en 2021 elle a mis
vilud a traité ainsi 148 saisines qui
sont en lien avec le complotisme et le
mouvement antivax alors les partisans de
théorie du complot de contre-vérité
scientifiques ne sont pas tous dans des
dérives sectaires le fait de croire
autre chose ou de développer son corpus
de contre-vérité n'est pas répréhensible
en soi mais on le voit bien il y a des
zones de contact qui existent est une
notion voisine explique la mi-vilud
certains chercheurs ont même trouvé un
néologisme pour désigner ces zones de
rencontres entre complotisme et des
rives sectaires il s'agit de la
conspiritualité merci beaucoup à mon
aura appris ce mot la conspiritualité
Thomas hussonge vous voyez évidemment
réagir et j'avais prévu de venir vers
vous après la chronique de de Tam est-ce
que on a on a on a un peu commencé à y
répondre le complotisme peut servir de
porte d'entrée d'une certaine façon à
une dérive se
exactement je voudrais juste donner un
truc au thème en fait c'est possible de
vérifier que la terre est ronde et c'est
possible de le faire il suffit d'avoir
un copain qui habite à quelques
kilomètres centaines de kilomètres de
chez vous c'est encore mieux vous prenez
exactement le même bateau les deux
personnes prennent de même bâton elles
vont tenir ce bâton au même moment de la
journée et on pourra calculer la taille
de l'ombre portée sur le sol ainsi on
peut même calculer la distance entre la
Terre et le Soleil c'est finalement pas
si facile de déconstruire un certain
nombre de théories complotistes mais ça
demande effectivement souvent plus de
temps que le mensonge justement on y est
Thomas c'est exactement ça le problème
le problème c'est que le temps que
la contradiction viennent s'apporter à
un discours de radicalisation quel qu'il
soit complotistes sectaire djihadiste
politique et bien il va falloir avoir le
temps de réfléchir à tout ça tous les
exemples que vous donnez Times à
l'instant montrent bien quelque chose
c'est que c'est pas possible de prouver
que quelque chose qui n'existe pas
n'existe pas et donc du coup on se
retrouve totalement
presque démuni face à tout un tas de
discours qui circulent aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux et qui ont déjà dit sont
plus amplifiés par les machines que
limiter par ces machines et donc le
complotisme qui a pris une énorme
ampleur dans la société française
aujourd'hui et bien c'est devenu une
forme de porte d'entrée effectivement
c'est le premier pas vers tout un tas
d'autres dérives et surtout tout un tas
de choses qui vont vous amener à
modifier votre comportement soit votre
comportement alimentaire votre
comportement vis-à-vis de la science là
on écoutait
ce tal chaleur nous entre spécialistes
du domaine on l'appelle tal golden
chaleur parce qu'il dit aussi qu'il faut
boire son urine pour aller mieux donc on
est vraiment sur des personnes qui ont
des des discours absolument sidérant
mais
comme ils sont séparés d'une forme de
raison ils sont sur leur propre page et
sur laquelle il n'y a pas de
contradiction et bien on se retrouve là
dans une espèce de mécanique qui est
terrible on parle des réseaux sociaux ce
qu'on a vu aussi avec la pandémie c'est
que maintenant des systèmes de
messagerie instantanées je pense
notamment à la plateforme télégram sont
devenus de nouveaux médias du
complotisme dans lequel les antivax les
gourous 2.0 chassés par les grandes
plateformes retrouvent une nouvelle
forme d'audience et là c'est encore pire
que pire il y a même plus de
contradictions ni d'observation
extérieure là on est vraiment dans une
espèce de cauchemar démocratique merci
Thomas il y a aussi une notion de
business évidemment c'est nouveau
gourous internet c'est aussi un outil
qui permet de faire de la publicité
d'attirer le salon quoi on peut dire les
choses on voit par exemple beaucoup
beaucoup de publicités des du mouvement
rahélien donc Raël on se dirait bah
c'est fini ça c'était les années 70-80
non non vous avez plein de pubs là en ce
moment sur Facebook
le mouvement réélien
et donc voilà donc oui il y a
effectivement un business à faire très
clairement avec les croyances avec on
parlait tout à l'heure des méthodes de
médecine alternative qui non de médecine
que le nom mais on va vous promettre
tout un tas de choses et c'est peut-être
plus facile encore pardon de nous
interrompre de faire du business quand
on est justement dans ce domaine de la
santé en tout cas de de fausthérapie
officiellement on ne vante pas de la
croyance on vend de la du savoir un
savoir caché un savoir qu'on ne veut pas
nous montrer parce que en fait c'est
trop simple et ça irait contre les
intérêts de Big Pharma etc donc au
départ quand on arrive je pense que
c'est le cas aussi pour une secte on
arrive dans un dans un mouvement qui
nous propose des solutions qui nous
proposent de nous aider
psychologiquement qui nous proposent des
solutions pour notre santé notre
bien-être etc et c'est le de fil en
aiguille en fait qu'on entre dans une
croyance sans se rendre compte et ça
c'est sans doute la porte la plus
difficile la porte d'entrée la plus
difficile à identifier
il y a un avant et un après covid en la
matière parce qu'il y a eu l'isolement
de la période il y a eu les craintes
liées à la maladie les délires de
certains antivax et surtout ça ça a créé
le terreau et je voudrais revenir sur
une chose c'est effectivement c'est la
responsabilité de l'État de donner aux
gens les outils et effectivement on a
des choses à faire en termes notamment
d'éducation à l'information les chiffres
qui ont été donnés tout à l'heure on
peut y ajouter que 30% des jeunes
croient à la sorcellerie enfin on peut y
ajouter plein de choses il y a pas que
les jeunes il y a pas que les jeunes
c'est la personne qui un vecteur aussi
mais il y a au moins au niveau de
l'éducation nationale et c'est un
engagement qui a été pris par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale au
moment des assises quelque chose à faire
en matière d'éducation de l'information
on voit pas arriver n'importe quel
contenu de la même manière selon s'il
est prouvé ou non et puis il y a un
outil qui est très important qui est ce
qu'on appelle le très bon King alors
Thomas Huchon va savoir exactement de
quoi je parle c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
ben quand aujourd'hui vous cherchez le
jeûne par exemple ou New Age ou et bien
finalement vous allez voir tous les
gourous arrivés en premier dans votre
dans votre
résultat de recherche et bien notre rôle
c'est de fournir des outils vous parliez
de la Terre plate tout à l'heure et on a
eu un exposé rapide de Thomas Huchon
pour expliquer que non et bien compliqué
certains en tout cas de ce qu'on a vu
sont d'accord pour signer avec nous un
accord pour dire et bien effectivement
on peut pousser ses contenus là parce
que ils n'ont pas d'intérêt à être
accusés d'avoir favorisé évidemment en
termes de réputation il n'y a pas
d'intérêt donc si effectivement si on
arrive à mettre à pousser des contenus
il reste ça n'enlève pas la liberté des
gens de croire que la terre est plate
tout le monde a le droit de croire en ça
mais au moins de donner aux gens de
l'information vérifier vérifiables
scientifique qui arrive avant le reste
ce qui a pas parfois un risque que ce
soit contre-productif dans le sens quand
on donne un label de nouvelles qui
soient vérifiées etc ou par le
gouvernement ou par un autre organisme
que justement ça crée l'effet inverse
qu'on se dise ah ben on nous ment etc ça
fait si l'émetteur c'est le gouvernement
et forcément après on fait rien enfin
notre rôle c'est quand même d'agir la
question vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
beaucoup de la santé notre rôle c'est
aussi de dire aux gens qu'est-ce qui est
une pratique qu'est-ce qui est un
praticien
agréé qui ne l'est pas qui qui organise
des dérives sectaires qui n'ont ça c'est
notre rôle c'est fait partie également
de les engagements du je suis d'accord
avec vous effectivement ça peut avoir un
effet contre-productif mais parce qu'on
pense souvent au plus convaincu quand on
réfléchit à ça il faut toujours penser à
la masse modérée il faut toujours penser
à ceux qui en fait n'ont pas vraiment
d'avis sur la question qui vont tomber
sur un sujet et qui vont tomber dans la
bulle de filtre du complotisme ou de la
dérive sectaire et ces gens-là en
général ils sont pas dans une défiance
radicale contre la science contre même
contre je veux dire même contre les
informations de d'origine
gouvernementale je veux dire voilà donc
ces gens-là quand ils voient
un label mais en tout cas quand tu vois
certains contenus sont poussés à ce
moment là ils se disent bon voilà enfin
il y a quand même j'ai un mec dont je ne
connais pas la provenance qui m'explique
la terre est plate et à côté j'ai Google
qui me dit attention cette information
n'est pas une information voici un lien
vers vers comment la Terre voilà une
explication scientifique sur comment la
Terre s'est constituée un mot rapide sur
le Thomas Huchon l'attitude des des
gafams ou des médias sociaux c'est à
dire que on vous l'a visité un peu tout
à l'heure mais quand je disais encore
faut-il qu'il pousse le bon contenu sauf
que leur modèle économique repose sur
pas vraiment là dessus quoi c'est en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que la
puissance publique peut les contraindre
à mettre en avant le référencement c'est
le référencement c'est ce qui décide de
ce que vous allez voir par exemple quand
vous faites une recherche sur Google
bien les premiers résultats qui tombent
sont les résultats les plus cliqués on
estime que grosso modo quand vous posez
une question à Google 90% des clics se
concentrent dans les trois premiers
résultats qui vous sont proposés ça veut
dire que on pourrait si on arrivait à
les contraindre à mettre en avant des
contenus triés sur le volet
effectivement avoir une forme d'impact
car un impact est pas négligeable comme
le rappelait Jean-Loup il faut on
imagine toujours que les discours
doivent convaincre les convertis mais
c'est pas ça c'est des discours ils
doivent servir pour l'immense majorité
des gens qui sont indécis les croyants
de leur côté les rationalises de l'autre
au milieu il y a 90% de la population
qui a juste envie de trouver des
réponses aux questions qu'elle se posent
et bien vu que des complotistes et des
gourous 2.0 les le rêve de réponses
c'est aussi notre rôle à nous
professionnelle de l'information pouvoir
public aussi et bien de mettre en avant
ces réponses afin que quand quelqu'un
pose une question il ne trouve pas
systématiquement la plus mauvaise des
réponses il y a aussi des faux muscler
son esprit critique en quelque sorte
c'est ce que vous défendez vous oui
c'est vrai que moi je propose des
contenus qui amènent à réfléchir sur soi
sur sa manière de penser et sur les
croyances qu'on a pourquoi on croise
qu'on croit donc c'est un peu voilà le
cœur de mon activité au travers de
témoignages et notamment de témoignages
de personnes qui sont sortis d'emprise
mentale que ce soit par exemple une
secte liée au yoga ou l'anthroposophie
effectivement j'ai fait une émission
avec Grégoire Perrat qu'on voyait tout à
l'heure dans le reportage ou le Tantra
ou le Reiki enfin voilà des activités
qui au départ peuvent être attirantes et
puis qui peuvent amener à des à de
l'emprise mentale et l'idée pour moi
c'est évidemment pas de dire ah ben vous
êtes concerné par le yoga ou par les
Témoins de Jéhovah ou etc mais plutôt de
se dire en tant qu'auditeur de mon
podcast ah ben ok j'ai jamais été dans
les Témoins de Jéhovah mais ce que
j'entends tout à coup dans ce témoignage
là me renvoie à un mode de pensée que
j'ai pu avoir ou une situation que j'ai
vécue ou une personne à ma famille qui
n'est pas forcément liée aux Témoin de
Jéhovah mais qui il y a un processus
mental qui est cousin qui est parents de
ce que je peux connaître et à ce
moment-là effectivement se dire tiens il
faudrait peut-être que je sois un peu
plus vigilante à telle ou telle chose je
prenne un peu de recul par rapport à une
croyance que j'ai par exemple l'esprit
critique c'est une très très c'est un
très bon point de départ
je me sens le simple fait de se poser la
question déjà une grande vérité
face à des nouveaux médias et c'est vrai
que voilà on essaye humblement ici aussi
d'y participer Mathilde est-ce qu'il y a
des législations par exemple dans
d'autres pays en Europe ou à l'étranger
qui pourrait nous inspirer des
mécanismes qui ont été mis en place des
choses que vous avez tout à fait
partisans du système français moi
personnellement je trouve que un système
qui a été construit qui a été construite
au qui était qui était bien construit
qui a été un peu abandonné
malheureusement à une période où ça
intéressait plus grand monde mais on a
un outil qui fonctionne bien qui
fonctionnera j'espère de nouveau très
bien bientôt qui est l'ami vilud qui est
donc la munition interministérielle de
vigilance et de lutte contre les
sectaires c'est un voilà c'est un outil
unique au monde qui n'existe nulle part
ailleurs parce que c'est aussi une
spécificité française que d'interroger
la croyance et de lui dédier un espace
et de veiller à ses dérives et je pense
que dans le dans le dans le monde actuel
dans ce qui est en train de se passer
dans un monde qui a un monde poste covid
je pense qu'on voit la pertinence de ce
modèle les Japonais qui sont venus nous
voir pour nous demander justement des
enfin comment fonctionner notre système
parce qu'il est considéré comme un
exemple là-bas donc ça marche pas bien
pas tout bien en tout cas il y a plein
de choses à améliorer c'est ce sur quoi
on travaille mais on n'est pas les
pierres merci moi j'ai une question
vous disiez 25%, ça veut dire combien de
personnes ça veut dire trois personnes
d'ici la fin de l'année en plus mais ça
va bien au-delà de ça
c'est pas le sujet enfin on verra
définitif
d'accord ok définitif mais juste
très vite l'idée c'est pas que la
mi-vilaine c'est d'avoir des référents
partout sur le territoire national merci
beaucoup rapidement les titres de volume
Jean-Louis desore le nouveau périple
sectaire c'est publié chez Robert
Laffont et puis Thomas Huchon anti fake
news aux éditions First coécrit avec
Jean-Bernard Schmitt merci à toutes et à
tous c'est la fin de cette émission je
vous donne rendez-vous
lundi et demain
dans la matinale c'est du carbonate
Lemaire socialiste d'Alfortville ancien
sénateur et ancien député qui sera face
à Oriane Mancini